مزيد من الضغوط الخارجيه على انقره لفنيه
عن شني عمليه بريه في الشمال السوري اخر
تلك الضغوط حملتها مكالمه وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجي شوريجو الى نظيره التركي خلص
يا كار
وفق وزاره الدفاع التركيه طالب بتجنب هجوم
واسع النطاق فرد اكار بان اولويه تركيا هي
درء التهديدات الارهابيه وبشكل دائم مذكرا
باهميه الامتثال للاتفاقيات السابقه في
هذا الشان وبعد يوم من اتصال رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه بنظره التركي مطالبا
اياه بالتهدئه دعت الخارجيه الامريكيه
تركيا الى وقف فوري للتصعيد في شمال سوريا
قائله على لسان المتحدث باسمها النواشر
تتفهم مخاوف انقر الامنيه المشروعه لكنها
تخشى جديه من تاثيرات ذلك على مواجهه
تنظيم الدوله وعلى المدنيين في المنطقه
حتى الان على الاقل لا يبدو ان تلك الضغوط
المتلاحقه تنال من تصميم انقره على المذي
قدما في تهديداتها مؤكده ان سعه الصفر
ستكون في الوقت الملائم وفي ضوء مشاورات
يجريها القاده السياسيون والعسكريون خزينه
قوتنا المسلحه والطائرات الحربيه تدمر
اوكار الارهابي بعملياتها في شمال العراق
وسوريا وهي الاماكن التي تم فيها التخطيط
للعمليات الارهابيه في تركيا هناك اعضاء
برلمان غير مرتاحين لهذا الامر اقول لهم
اننا سنكون حيث يكون الارهاب من خلال
مخابراتنا وقواتنا المسلحه
وفي اليوم الخامس من ما تسميه تركيا عمليه
المخلب السيف اردنا على تفجير اسطنبول
الدامي كسف سلاح الجو التركي غارته على
مواقع ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
واعلن المتحدث باسم تلك القوات مقتل عناصر
منها في غارات استهدفت محيط مخيم الهول
حيث يقبع الاف النازحين وافراد من عائلات
تنظيم الدوله في شمال شرق سوريا ولا تخلو
المواجهه في هذه المناطق من مخاطر لا سيما
بعد ان اكده القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
ان ضربه عسكريه
استهدفت يوم الثلاثاء الماضي قاعده عسكريه
مشتركه لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والتحالف
الدولي بقياده واشنطن في محافظه الحسكه
عرضت جنود امريكيين للخطر وهي حوادث قد تش
رافعه للجماعات الكرديه المسلحه في هذه
المواجهه المنذره بالاسوا